senior Department of Justice official
telling our own Jay Gibson quote special
counsel Muller is not recommending any
further indictments again the news
coming from the Department of Justice a
senior DOJ official quote special
counsel Robert Muller not recommending
any further indictments actually not
significant bread although I think it's
autumn when it comes to this you know
the question we're all waiting finally
at long last but the answer to this on
this question of collaboration it's been
discussed at some length throughout all
this whether if there were such
collaboration it would be a crime and if
mr. Muller decides that no indictments
should ensue because of that that
doesn't necessarily mean he didn't find
any improper hanky-panky between the
between the the calm campaign and the
Russians it may just be that he felt it
wasn't criminal now my own sense about
this is that it's hard to imagine that
has come as far as we have was as much
effort has been made to investigate this
whole matter both inside and outside the
government that if there'd been any such
thing that we wouldn't have heard about
it by now but it's it is worth keeping
in mind that now there is this legal
question of whether if it if it had been
turned up it would have even been a
crime and therefore whether there if
there are no further indictments that
might might not mean that they found
nothing nothing improper sure yeah I
mean there's a lot that we don't know
yet but that sentence in and of itself
after all of the months and months of
speculation of what could happen the
fact that they are saying that this
Special Counsel report does not
recommend any further indictments is
significant in and of itself just on its
face it's right to point out that the
Southern District of New York is
continuing its investigation that there
are more investigations on Capitol Hill
but if this report Britt does not
deliver the punch that perhaps critics
of the President or Democrats had had
hoped it would and it seemed like it the
coverage over recent days there was a
preparation for that fact up on Capitol
Hill if it doesn't will the president
then take that and say see I told you so
you need to stop and move on and get
things done yeah he undoubtedly will say
that and I would suggest this Brett that
the Democrats on Capitol Hill have
already been signaling that even if he
doesn't find anything in the
neighborhood of collaboration that that
he that they intend to pursue that issue
further particularly Adam Schiff on the
House Intelligence Committee contends to
pursue that I think if Muller comes out
and there is nothing suggesting improper
behavior between the president and the
Russians before the election I think a
lot of the political wind will go out of
those sails because a lot of people
gonna look at this and say come on I
mean you've been talking you've been you
know we've been pursuing this all this
time now Muller who's blowing away the
report is upon us he didn't find
anything what are you doing so my sense
about that is that that while those
investigations might drag on they may
have to drag on with a lot less media
attention than they once would have
hoped for